[Music]
all right so let's do this I want to do
gun 101 with you okay all the things
that we should know about guns and then
I want to do the most common
misconceptions about guns because I
think part of the issue right now is
every time something happens every time
there's a shooting half the people don't
know anything about guns on one hand
half the people then give you all of
those misconceptions it can't sit
confusing for everybody and even the
people who I generally trust now I sense
don't know exactly what they're saying
so I want to do a video with you right
now every time one of these incidences
happen and someone starts asking me this
asking me that I want to go I've got the
thing that I can point to with the
answers so let's do gun what a lock on
what do we need to know about that all
right first of all most a r does not
stand for assault rifle so when I say
ar-15 that's not assault rifle does not
mean assault rifle an assault rifle is a
gun that is fully automatic right that
means I pull the trigger I hold it back
and it expends all of the ammunition in
the magazine that's that's Jesse Ventura
in predator boom okay it's a great gun
yeah love that gun right I can argue
about not gonna side with mine owning it
so okay so that's automatic that just
hold it down and down in it it will fire
every round
subsequently until it's completely out
okay right and that's so at a very high
rate of speed
okay generally speaking somebody
automatic so now there's been this thing
where people conflate this or use semi
automatic as a kind of a hyperbolic way
of characterizing guns as death killing
machines right
virtually every modern gun is
semi-automatic and what that means is
one press of the trigger you get one
bullet versus holding the trigger down
once and getting all the bullets okay so
that's a great distinction out there
because often when this happens you see
people saying we have to ban semi
automatics yes semi automatic that's
virtually every month so it's not
because all that the only difference
between that and a what a fully
automatic well what's one that you're
just loading one bullet in okay so that
would be a bolt-action okay right so
there's fully automatic semi-automatic
and bolt-action right right bolt-action
more
as more lines like like hunting right or
hyper high precision shooting and it's a
both because it allows you to build a
gun up in such a way where you it's the
tighter constraints within a gun and it
allows you to be more accurate okay
without certain mechanism moving back
and forth causing throwing off the
accuracy of the shot so you would say
then that when when all of these people
come out and say we have to ban semi
automatics that they are actually just
flat-out confused or intentionally
conflating or obfuscating what the truth
is related to them yes absolutely
and so it's either they're confused
ignorant or they're doing a purpose
field like you just stated
okay so what is the so let's do some nra
stuff while we're doing this what is the
nra stance on automatics just being able
to hold and shoot I mean the way it's
currently regulated is the way it stands
like right now there's like in order to
get an automatic gun there's a certain
process you have to go through in order
to get them and and that it's been that
way for a very long time now and that's
been that it exists yeah as it does now
and that's essentially war where the
stance is it with respect to fully
automatic well what are people use in
fully automatic guns for so because I
think this is where you hear people go
well no one needs an automatic to hunt
well see here's the thing no it's it's
it's the idea of putting it under the
guise of needing right there name
another right where we use that same
standard you know Beck's question that's
so it's like okay you haven't fully
automatic gun and you have
semi-automatic guns you have bolt-action
there are different reasons why you
would want each of these guns now I can
delve into that but then that starts
getting into the very nerdy side of
firearm ownership where the enthusiasts
aspect of that comes into it is
understanding tactically why you would
want certain things and so for me I'm
not personally I don't have a problem
with people on the fully automatic guns
personally I just don't see that as a
significant danger above and beyond say
owning a nuclear suitcase right so if
people tried to make that absurd
argument to me before I well then won't
you be loved and well that's because
there's there's a cost-benefit ratio
that doesn't make any sense right that
you just that's inherently
self-destruction
so how is this how was that protecting
you in any way from the very thing that
you're supposed to be checking yourself
against do you think there should be a
higher threshold to be able to get an
automatic than some of the other weapons
you're talking about me personally
threshold in what respect like in terms
of either hire back graded background
checks or references so let's talk about
background checks every minute so
there's this i dentist notion that we
don't have background checks for our
guns we do and a funny thing is we in
the gun community we have become a
victim of technology and what i mean by
that is people think that just because i
can go into a guns if I really wanted to
I can do a gun store right now buy a gun
within two minutes just like that
you can't yeah because you've done all
of the the background stuff see that's
the thing though I'm still going under
I'm undergoing the same processes right
so I go into the store I find a gun I
like this gun I said I want to buy this
gun I fill out the 44s form 4473 which
asked me a series of questions then they
take that information and they submit it
to the FBI database and they do a
background check but it happens
instantly because technology right
people it's interesting because there's
a lot of people who feel like I said
undergo some type of CIA investigation
before I buy a gun the same people who
also hate the government exactly right
so when they the instant aspect of the
background check causes people who don't
know very much about the process to
think that there isn't one right just
because I can buy the gun easily doesn't
mean it was done thoroughly mm-hmm
you know what I'm saying I underwent the
background check there's a system there
they checked it against the system if I
don't have any felonies or anything that
prevents me from owning that firearm I'm
allowed to buy the gun okay so when
people say there are there are no
background checks and Matt ground checks
aren't tight enough or however you want
to extract that is there any credence to
any of that so now let's talk so I think
what you're what you're kind of going
into is the universal background checks
right so when they say universal back
now they do conflate these terminologies
there's the universal background check
is a very specific statement it's it's
not like saying Coke right because
people here universal background checks
on other here's the background check
part that Universal means something and
what that means is it's a requirement
that on
every single transaction you have to
undergo a background check even private
transactions right so right now in
California if I had a gun right I can
bring a gun into California I just can't
carry it but you were like hey you know
Kant's I like that gun you have right
what I buy for me in California I can't
sell it to you mm-hmm
right now what here's what I can do I
could say all right cool when I get back
to Texas I'll transfer the gun to a gun
store here in California if it's on the
specific list that allows you to
actually own that gun right because
California has exactly yeah and then you
would have to go to the gun store and
then buy it right now let's say I
decided to give you the gun anyway
privately right now in this room no one
else is here but you and I and I sell do
you've a gun give each other cameras oh
yeah I mean you know I don't have any
plans on going to jail but and I sell
you the gun you and then let's say you
have the gun what is there - checked
against what database is there to check
against this determine whether or not
you got a background check for that gun
now just completely two issues right now
yeah so well if we get it on the DL
there there's no there's no way and
that's what the whole concept of the
universal background check is it is to
require a background check for every
private transaction now legally right
now I can't do it but like in Texas I
can sell a gun to a friend and as long
as I know he's not a prohibited person
and I know he's not a felon I can sell
him that gun no problems that's
completely legal what the universal
background check idea suggest is I
should have I should be required to
undergo a background check before I can
sell in that gun now I mean you and he
and I would have to go to a gun store
and undergo a background check then he
can go and buy the gun from me so is the
problem with the way it is currently
saying Texas the way you're describing
that you just would not know potentially
enough information about the person you
were selling yes that that's a potential
absolutely and so the reason why I'm
against the universal background check
is because there is no other way to
enforce it but for a national gun
registry because otherwise you have
nothing to check it against right to say
is if I if a cop walks down the street
sees you have a gun he's like do your
background check for the gun yeah
how's he gonna prove otherwise unless
there's a national registry then it was
okay fine well then let's have a
national registry no because we've seen
time and time again and when the
government's have a national registry of
firearms they subsequently use it to
confiscate guns now the problem is when
you say that they try to put the tinfoil
hat on you right except because what
they what they envision is you know
roaring Clark black military trucks
coming down the street pulling guns from
people's houses no that's not what
happens or how they do it it's
constructive and then when you have
potential presidential candidates like
Hillary Clinton suggesting we should
take a part we should take up the
Australia model which did that very
thing they use the National they use a
national gun registration to tell people
to say you know what you need to turn in
your guns it's a voluntary buyback no
it's an in the mandatory buyback right
so and if you don't sell your guns back
guess what you go to jail
that's a confiscation yeah it's a
constructive confiscation but a
compensation nonetheless just because
they didn't roll the military trucks
down the street and pull them out of
your house doesn't mean it isn't
confiscation and so that's why I'm I'm
adamantly against universal background
checks unless you can demonstrate it
away from me for it to be applied in
such a way that would not require gun
registry because I do not trust my
government not to exploit that registry
in their favor
yeah so how much of this then because
we've talked about it you said to me
right before we started you're sort of a
libertarian I think it's exactly he said
I don't want to put worry about how much
of this does go back to that states
should be able to make the decisions
that they see fit I mean I suspect you
probably wouldn't be that thrilled
living in California other than the
weather I I'm here in California whether
the women that's pretty good food yeah
we do yeah I might complain about that
so see that's just it too it's like well
how far those states rights go from the
standpoint of violating my Second
Amendment right right
I believe in states rights right at some
point you start violating my
constitutional ones and so when you have
places like California which I think I
think I'm being currently violated now
that
that I can't carry my mic on what is the
difference I can take my I can take my
car with my Texas license and drive it
right into California no one has a
problem with that I can drive up and
down these roads and as fast as I want
as recklessly as I want yeah that might
be illegal but I still do it does that
potentially do it but yet I can't carry
the thing that I carry to protect my
life with the same license does it make
some sense to me like am i any in any
less danger here then I would be in
Texas if anything I can make the
argument that I'm more there's more
danger for me here in that I don't know
the area very well so in a weird way
you're actually making an on states
rights argument here because if you're
saying you want the same thing
everywhere that's a that's not a states
rights argument it's not that but that's
what I'm saying
yeah because but that that's under the
guise of me feeling like me not being
able to carry as a violation of my
constitutional right right because
states rights doesn't allow them to
violate those constitutional rights and
that's that's the argument I'm making
now it's difficult because then you
start talking about the idea of having a
uniform like concealed carry platform
right where one license allows you to
carry a gun everywhere right then you
start getting into weeds but okay well
that's violating states rights that's
only if you don't see my ability to
carry a firearm as a as a sorry my
ability to carry a firearm as a
violation of my constitutional right
right so it's an interesting
philosophical place to talk because it's
like it just depends where you start
yeah because even though I'm definitely
a states rights guy I hear what you say
there and then on the other hand as a
states rights guy to me if a state wants
to have stricter laws and you're a big
gun guy than you actually are allowed to
leave it's kind of as I would say for
virtually every other situation it's
kind of shitty it doesn't feel great to
have to leave a place that you want to
be at but if they're doing things as
part of their state experiment that you
don't like well done it's on you to get
gone yeah but if that same state creates
a law that violates my right to privacy
right well we have constitutional right
that's super C so I see so I get I get a
chair are we missing anything else on
the technical front because we did that
pretty calm oh you'll see
[Applause]
from a mechanical state right yeah just
from the mechanical standpoint or just
any of the language that we use related
to this okay okay so yeah so then of
course there's some people can say it's
trivial some people say it's not so the
magazine versus clip it's yeah the
general term it's actually it's called
the magazine a clip is an actual thing
it's just different from a magazine that
that's kind of slightly trivial but it
does typically kind of expose people who
don't really know much about guns
when you say clip versus magazine
because the proper terminology would be
magazine as far as any other mechanical
components yeah well what do I need to
know about the magazine well that's just
terminology it is semantics yeah right I
don't always go about correcting people
because I feel like it just creates
something it kind of makes me look like
an ass but that's why we're doing it
yeah and I want to clean somehow the
biggest thing is it's just the assault
weapon thing right because the ar-15 is
a civilian weapon it's it's designated
the biggest difference between an ar-15
and an assault rifle is that the assault
rifle is fully automatic and they are 15
isn't that's the biggest distinction
between the two now of course then you
can make the argument well that's some
very minor distinction you know there
are a lot of people who make that
argument but I don't look at the ar-15
any differently than I look at the
handgun in that sense okay so every time
when one of these happens and we hear
the ar-15 is a weapon of war solo
handguns you would basically put the
ar-15 in the handgun in the same
category yes as pulling ones Shiban ones
yeah so that would not be categorized as
a weapon of war we'll see that's the
destination that terminology is designed
to to manipulate the emotions of people
who don't know anything about guns so
when you hear if you don't know anything
about firearms and you hear he's the
weapon of war technically speaking all
guns or weapons of war right swords can
be weapons exactly yeah so but what that
does mentally like they understand
language very well yeah they like
they're like not human but in terms of
the I call it the anti-gun side of it of
things they understand the use of
language very well and and they confuse
it purposely so when you hear someone
who doesn't know anything about firearms
think about it like if if I'm already
kind of I'm a little scared of firearms
and then I hear he used a weapon of war
what image comes up in your mind it's
it's Rambo you know he's running down
there just going crazy and that's
exactly what he's doing
but he could do the same thing with a
handgun and so the biggest thing that I
like to when I'm having these
conversations with peoples you're gonna
walk away with you can walk away with
two with two points of two trains of
thoughts I'm either gonna get you to
admit you just want to ban all guns or
you can see my perspective because if
you if you're willing to say you know
what we need to get rid of all this salt
weapons as they as they understand them
to be which is essentially ar-15s but
now it's actually becoming more broader
like me to get rid of all semi-automatic
weapons right that's virtually every
modern gun so let's say they move they
want to ban ar-15s ar-15 rifles aren't
even used like the percentage that
rifles are used in actual shootings is
so low and marginal it's unreal so then
why are we focusing on it but okay then
what are most shootings
they're handguns yeah right so if you
get rid of that and we got rid of ar-15
and then we have another shooting
happening because the are loves deadly
school mass shooting was Virginia Tech
and he used a hangar so then what
happens if that happens again so now
what are you gonna ban you gonna ban
handgun and that's when you're stuck
having to confront the fact that okay
either you really just want to ban all
guns or you understand that the
distinction is irrelevant right we've
got to get to the absolute point of
issue and why these things are happening
and focusing on the gun is doing a
disservice to the conversation it sounds
like I'm just utilizing I'm using a
bigger issue as a scapegoat but in
reality if you really sit down and think
about it all right
we have over 300 close to 400 million
guns in this country going in
and understanding that you've got to
then sit down and say to yourself all
right if we're gonna try to fix this
issue of gun violence or just violence
in general we've got to get to the root
of issue of why people are doing it and
then understanding that staying within
the context of reality we've got to
understand well in the process I still
have to protect myself and because
people are still still gonna be able to
get their hands on guns whether legal or
not and and use them to commit crimes in
the brain people's lives I've got to be
put in a situation to defend against
that so you can ban all the ar-15
doesn't mean it's gonna stop somebody
from getting one on a black market so
now yes I don't run from the fact that
the ar-15 is a more powerful platform
dad I agree with and I don't think I
don't run from that they're gonna be
people on there who are gonna be mad at
me for saying that but the reason I
don't ruffle mint is because that's the
very reason why I want an ar-15 when it
comes to defending my life I don't want
it to be a fair fight mm-hmm
period I don't want to have to confront
someone with an ar-15 with the handgun
if I don't have to if you come in my
house I'm not grabbing a handgun I'm
grabbing an ar-15 see we have this
strange thing it's like when people will
say okay well the Second Amendment has
the right to bear arms and then they'll
put up a picture of you know the type of
arms that existed way back when and it's
like well then we should be have the
right to that because that's what they
were talking about it like this is so
disingenuous and genuine it's like they
were also talking about why you should
be able to form a militia and it's like
the thing that we'd be fighting against
now has a lot more power and it doesn't
mean that just because you have some
guns you're gonna be able to stop the
guys in the black box as you talked
about earlier but maybe you could defend
yourself a little bit longer and who
knows what happens with a little bit of
time I mean fruit and be real with that
they're still fighting in Afghanistan
and those guys over there just using
ak-47s you know what I'm saying so like
we can't just because we're gonna lose
there something you just lie down and do
it you know and in the hope that the
whole notion of like hey man I just lost
my train of thought the this idea of
owning firearms to combat the government
it's it may think it's preposterous but
I'm like ask the people in Venezuela
what's going on again these are now the
people at least in this current moment
people who say that the government is
run by orange Hitler exactly and it
really well well this is a good spot to
I think changed some minds and as I said
to you before we sat down I've never
considered myself a gun person per se
I'm interested I'm always interested in
talking about these things but I do find
myself now more pro-gun it's probably
not even the right phrase to say yeah
then I've ever been in my life and then
but that for me it has more to do it
that I'm really understanding what
rights are in a much clearer way and and
what I want the government to do and not
undo and once you understand that then
you know it's tough it's tough to take
other positions it is weak so is there
anything to you that when they always
say sensible gun control and I always
see the the pro-gun people will say well
the people that always say that just
don't know what they're talking about
and I sense you're probably in that spot
cuz that you would just say like I do
with language yeah so sensible gun
control most of some people say that
they actually advocating so we already
have background checks things of that
nature right and then you like and you
have other language like the loop the
gun show the gun gun show loophole yeah
let's talk about that's not a loophole
all that all that is is a private
transaction that's all that is and it's
just happening happening it just so
happens happen at a gun show if you
bought a gun from an actual dealer at a
gun show you still have to undergo a
background check so the when they say
loophole what you're saying is that if
you are at a gun show you're not a
dealer yeah you can't actually sell that
gun at if you are if one the person is
not a prohibited possessor you are from
the same state then yes okay if there's
nothing that precludes them from owning
a firearm legally I can sell them a gun
at a gun show right so the only slippery
part of that is what we talked about
earlier which is you just may not know
all the information exactly so there is
a there is I guess there's a little bit
of a gray area and that one is that a
fair in terms of you yeah that you're
sort of taking somebody's word for it at
that point
yes meet somebody that day and they're
like I want
and you say to that you ask them all the
appropriate questions they could be
lying to you absolutely but that's just
there but then that so then the way the
response that they have to that is he
give us a background check but as I
pointed out how do you how do you
enforce it without a national registry
and in with that national registry even
with the national registry it doesn't
stop anything right we tend to go down
this I just wrote of just wanting to do
things to make ourselves feel better but
in reality name one mass shooting that
would have been prevented with a
universal background check now one
because even the people who had guns who
weren't supposed to have them they got
them illegally mm-hmm right it wasn't
because there wasn't a universal
background check that stopped them from
getting it no it was it so I have to I
have to ask the question I don't and why
are we doing this other than just to
make ourselves feel better because it's
literally doing nothing nothing and so
that's why like the person who bought
and sold a gun privately at a at a gun
show could done that in the parking lot
of the gun show could have done it at
their house before going to the gun show
you get what I'm saying yeah but what it
does is when you frame it within the
context of the gun show loophole it
makes it seem like it's just bizarre
where everyone comes there together and
sells illegal guns right that's that
image that's created in mind I think
it's barter town exactly like they feed
on the they feed on the ignorance of
people yeah right because like they're
not everybody knows that much about guns
it's it's like it's one of those things
like I don't know I don't know a lot
about a lot of other things that people
may know a lot about right so if you
tell me something and I'm not really
researched and schooled on that issue
you could get me to believe some pretty
kooky stuff yeah and that's what I'm
talking about is what you consistently
see at any time we talked about this and
you know there's this other piece of it
where it's like every time a shooting
happens you know there's this pylon
where oh now now we should talk about it
and then there's this other part of us
where it's because we go from one crisis
to another that there's never really
seems to me at this point we never
really have time to really ever fully
unpack any of these things I think I
think there's moments like this but on a
national level we're not particularly
good at these
no cuz then what it does it just turns
into a political sparring match yeah I
mean right after the last shooting and
when Dana lotion and Rubio were on that
CNN Town Hall I mean it was it was
meaningful to me in the gladiatorial
fest it was a disaster lose it was
everything I hate about just the quick
bites and of all of this and flashiness
and just he can we take out right now it
was a disaster and then and I said and I
pointed this out how can we have a real
honest conversation when they try to
paint pro-gun people as crazy when we
say no the ultimate goal is to ban guns
but then I can watch a CNN live Town
Hall where Ruby will suggest you do
realize banning all semi-automatic guns
is essentially banning all guns in the
entire stadium erupts and applause and
cheers yeah so then I go yo Rubio said
exactly what you said
and they started cheering even even when
confronted with the core because Rubio
said look you want to bet on some night
amount of guns here let me educate you
really quickly and tell you that's
virtually all guns so even when he
corrected them so it wasn't they can't
they can't they can't claim they were
ignorant on it because he just explained
to them that means banning virtually all
guns and they upped it so it goes okay
so now you have all those programs alike
you're just gonna go back to our phones
and there's no discussion because well
while we're trying to be fair your
ultimate goal is to try to ban them all
yeah there was that moment I'm sure you
remember this after the Parkland
shooting when they had the big rally and
one of the survivors got up there and
said we're gonna come what was the line
you remember the exact line where she
said basically we're gonna come for the
semi automatics and now but we're gonna
come for everything later some something
to that effect them yeah I'm slightly
butchering it but I thought wow now
you're flat out saying and you're just
giving you're telling them now so I
could see why you know I see this with
all my frustrations when they're left
all the time it's like I know they're
never gonna stop I've seen it so
consistently and that's why I'm staking
out some positions but sometimes it's
it's kind of sucky to have to just be
like well the people that I'm
again so to speak they're not dealing in
the same world that I'm dealing in and I
and that makes it more important for me
to stake out a position but the thing
that's most frustrating about it is the
way they'll color it in the mainstream
media is that we're unreasonable we
don't want to move on inch we've dug our
hills in all we want is to be you don't
care about anything and really what it
is is no I let you into my house and now
you're trying to take my house from me
so get out just as essentially what
they're saying is all right so they'll
say well common sense that's why we hate
that word common sense because it kids
it's disingenuous it's like well we need
common-sense measures after a shooting
all right and another shooting happens
we need more common-sense measures and
another student happens we need even
more common-sense measures when does
common-sense measures stop being
common-sense than just intruding on my
rights yeah and I can see that you know
you know my thing for guns to use free
speech to me and it's like I can see
this coming with that if these guys took
control you'd start seeing well we could
have free speech but we need some
common-sense controls around reason
actually so I so I do understand the
position like I tell people all the time
I'm like there are over 300 federal gun
laws in this country I think we've been
reasonable I think we were really truly
being unreasonable we wouldn't have over
300 we're going well I can't begin to
tell you how many we have on a state
level right so it's incredibly
disingenuous to think that we're just
being hard hard-asses who don't want to
move one inch on the issue right no
one's saying it should be a free-for-all
where we're just handing out guns to
everyone like Oprah right I don't think
anybody has a problem inherently with
background checks now when you talk
about universal background checks that's
a different thing but since nobody since
they never want to make that distinction
right no one ever knows that you can't
you can't exactly and then the idea of
like you know we can talk about gun-free
zones right and it begs the questions
like what is that what does that sticker
on when they're gonna do for me
so now I have to make like people don't
really like to sympathize with gun
owners in the sense of like we all want
the same result right we want the
killing the stop we want the violence
notice I said violence and killing not
just gun violence right because we can't
just focus on gun violence because
violence is violence however you died
you died and it's bad all the way around
but when I have to make a decision about
whether or not I potentially break a law
to go into an establishment that may or
may not cause me to need my gun at some
point and that's messed up and I know
that there are a lot of people who don't
see it that way because they don't see
value in the Second Amendment because
they're not firearm owners right there
are a lot of people who look at the
Second Amendment is useless because they
don't own firearms but when you have a
group of people who understand the
importance of it and how it fits into
their lives
and they understand that at the end of
the day when something happens the only
person who's gonna be there to stop it
is you that's a big deal so it's not
just me trying to protect a piece of
metal because I just want to have fun
with my guns no it's much bigger than
that it's this idea that I have to rely
on myself you can tell me all day long
the police are gonna be there the police
are gonna be there but they're not going
to be there just not and then you think
they were at Parkland exactly right so
then you can you add kids family into
the mix that ratchet it up to a whole
nother level so about what about the
piece of this that just sort of optics
so you know every now and again you'll
see a picture of like three dudes with
big-ass guns at Chipotle you know like
an open carry now I know if I was if I
walked into Chipotle and three guys came
in with big-ass guns on their back yeah
well I would take notes and I probably
leave but I probably would I would just
be like you know looking again I'm here
I'm there in California where that would
be so bad so out of the door but let's
but for the person that's living in
Texas no home can do this if I was in
Chipotle right and three guys walking in
I probably would leave no one everything
that you just said they're knowing that
these guys are probably NRA members and
and as far as I know no NRA member has
ever done a mass you know right okay so
you know cuz you see this all tiny
celebrities Michael Ian Black like add
on the show who's on this rampage
telling everyone that you guys are
terrorists
really that you're you're part of a
terrorist organization I mean okay and
so are the five million members right
but I but I think there is something
about some of the optics a minute you
know I mean like I would be nervous now
I get your point would be well those
guys are gonna protect you when the
other guy walks in or whatever then some
of that may be feelings over facts right
there but it just it just is there
interesting thing about it that is a big
debate within the gun the gun community
as a whole the idea of open carry vers
concealed carry i don't ever open carry
except for maybe if I'm out hunting or a
mountain range or something like that i
but that's that's a personal decision
I'm choosing my own for various reasons
one sometimes I rather not have the
attention and tactically I like the
advantage of having the element of
surprise you don't know I have a gun on
me so if I had to use it I'm going to be
reacting alright I'm not going into a
place to shoot it up if somebody decides
to come into a place of [ __ ] about I'm
gonna be reacting to that so I need all
the advantages I get from my personal
perspective so I want the element of
surprise there's some people who think
in the alternative they feel like just a
mere presence of that gun is a deterrent
from anyone who wants to come in and do
some bad so if guys casing out a couple
of stores in a nice ease there are
certain citizens in there with long guns
and some that have handguns on the side
of the hip and that's a deterrent mmm
right I understand the alarm that people
who don't necessarily engage in interact
with firearms get when they see people
walking around with rifles right even I
thought there been I've seen a couple of
people in Texas to it and initially my
gut reaction and I'll admit it was like
what's going on here
now I'm very verse firearms and I have a
gun too so at that point I actually
almost welcome it and the reason why is
because if you're going to do something
I now get to see you attempt to do it
you get what I'm saying there's a
telegraph you are in a unique case on
this one yes but I'm speaking from
purely a place of personal yeah
preference right I'm not speaking on the
whole for anyone else things like that
me personally I would rather like to
know you have it right if I can see it
because then I know where to focus my
attention versus me kind of being alone
to a state of complacency because of its
absence and then all of a sudden
somebody stands up and decides he wants
to shoot the place up and then I have to
react to that
but again that's tactics right that's
that's this personal preference in that
regard however I do understand the alarm
that somebody you would have seeing
three guys walking to Chipotle with the
with rifles because it seems seemingly
especially to them they seems like
that's a bit excessive
come on a lot of you if I can conceal
carry rifle I would because it's better
at defending me than a handgun was the
only reason the only gonna have a
handgun is because a small enough for me
to conceal any Indian allows me to live
my life and an uninterrupted otherwise
I'd walk around with a rifle okay so we
can't end without doing sort of what I
think would be the big question for
everything we've talked about here and
for someone that works with the NRA and
your shows on NRA TV and all that so
what is going on in America right now
that seems to be unique to our society
we do have more shootings here than I
then I think virtually all other Western
nations combined so okay for you to fact
check me on that advice I don't read
that one but but it does seem it's and
even if I'm slightly oh no you're good
it seems that there is something
uniquely happening here now I would
argue that there's all sorts of mental
health issues and probably prescription
drugs and maybe non prescription drugs
and all sorts of other stuff so there's
a couple of things so I'll try to I've
tried to keep this as concise as
possible because we are gonna get into
weeds for it split second you got so
first of all let's talk about mass
shootings right our school school and so
for instance I recently just read a
study from Northwestern University
that's one which talked about comparing
the number of school and shootings back
in the 90s rest of the vs. today and
what they concluded essentially was the
perception is that it's happening more
frequently but it's not it's actually on
par or even less now than it was then
now you can people who can I go my god
how could you possibly say that Google
it it's a Northwestern University
research a camera with actual title of
the actual research but we're gonna grab
it from you after this and eyes link to
it in absolutely so that being said
mass shootings account for a very very
very marginal
percentage of shootings in this country
let's start off with the overall so 35
35 to 36 thousand people each year die
from guns right I didn't specify gun
violence but just guns because they
don't do that that was it's a gun
violence right so 60 about 16 to 65
percent of those that 35,000 is suicides
now what I'm not saying is we don't care
about suicides we do however when it
comes to the idea and the issue of
somebody shooting at me mm-hmm that's a
that's not it's not germane yeah but
then even still if you want to make the
argument well if we had less guns we'd
have less suicides that's also not true
because our suicide rate is on par with
every other major country so if it was
the case that the more guns you have the
more suicides we'd be leading the charge
we don't where there's a will there's a
way exactly Yeah right
even some or the more more famous
suicides we've had they didn't use guns
so we set that number side which is a
huge number yeah sixty-five percent is a
huge number out of 35 36 thousand so
then you have about one to three percent
which are justifiable homicides that's
self-defense that's including police
shooting criminals who are shooting at
them right and people who use guns in
self-defense right we got to set that
aside because that's not the issue we're
trying to address so set that number
side and then you have about five
percent which are accidental right Kate
gets finds a gun pull triggers
unfortunate extremely unfortunate
however I believe personally half of
that can easily be addressed with more
education so if we took the energy that
we took that we place now I'm trying to
vilify guns and have national campaigns
teaching people about gun safety that
will cut that number in half because a
lot of these accidents easily
preventable but they're just people who
are going to just don't know and so if
we spend time educating those people do
we know what percentage of that subset
is getting those guns legally or
illegally because I would imagine that a
lot of it's probably illegal which is
why they don't know how to use the gun
in the first I'm not gonna assume I have
that answer because I don't have that
hard number yeah
but and I would about I do feel
comfortable assuming
as well yeah right and so if we take
that accidents to set that aside purely
homicides we're looking at around seven
to ten thousand every year right now
that's a different looking number right
move you've accounted for all the
context here with those those other
shootings now the vast majority I say
close to eighty percent that I've read
and a couple of articles of those
homicides are happening in the inner
cities of our country all right so then
reason goes all right so let's look at
those inner cities and let's look at the
dynamics there right you have low jobs
lack of Economic Opportunity destroyed
households and a narco economy that
warrants that warrants but creates
necessity for this type of violence so
if we dealt with the socio-economic
aspects of what's going on in those
areas right
do we really have a gun problem just
think about it I know I know other
communities fill with black people they
have guns they don't have the same level
of violence cousin I only say black
people because most people associate the
inner city with with black people right
but the reason why we have that high
level of concentration of violence it's
because of the conditions in those
environments and even within those
communities there are the vast majority
of people in those communities are good
people and it's a very minor group of
people who are creating a large number
of the violence right so there's
something to be said do we really have a
gun problem or do we have a
socio-economic suicide problem in this
country because at the end of the day
there's thirty five to thirty six
thousand that people assuming is all gun
violence by way of homicides people
shooting at other people to kill them
it's not the case we're looking at close
to the seven to ten thousand if that and
so if you take those numbers and you
compare in other countries then how does
it look
to be continued yeah well I'm so glad
that we finally did this and we will
definitely do this again because I
absolutely this story and and everything
we've talked about here is just gonna
continue I mean these are the battles
that we're now fighting on many fronts
related to the Constitution and free
speech and free expression and your
ability to to own your life and all that
stuff and that's all we ask is that this
is us let me put in well say one last
thing yeah people there are a lot of
people who's like well how do you feel
the need to carry a gun why I like the
chances of you needing to use that gun
to protect yourself like 1% and the
answer I have for that is this you may
be right
chance' me need to carry actually use my
gun defend myself maybe really slim
maybe 1% but if that 1% happened it's a
hundred percent of everything the
consequences are a hundred percent and
that's why it's so important yeah all
right well that's how you end a show you
know you maybe we'll do this next time
maybe we'll bring you on with someone on
some of the other side of the issues on
things I will tell them we'll have that
conversation sounds like a plan
all right for more on colione check them
out on twitter mr. colleano our
[Music]